- [Lecturer] What we're going
to discuss in this video
is Executive Orders.
And these are directives being issued
by the President of the United States
that can have the force of law.
And I know what you're thinking,
isn't Congress our legislative body,
the body that actually creates the laws?
And is it the job of the President to be
the head of the Executive
Branch to execute on those laws?
And if you are thinking
that, you are correct.
But going all the way
back to George Washington,
Presidents have issued Executive Orders.
Some are fairly lightweight.
They might be a directive
for something to be done
in a certain way, or a small regulation,
or even appointing someone to a job.
But sometimes these Executive Orders
can be quite significant.
And the constitutional
justification for these Orders
come mainly from two different
statements in Article II
of the U.S. Constitution.
In Section One, it starts off saying,
"The Executive Power shall
be vested in a President
"of the United States of America."
And at the end of Section
Three, it says that,
"the President shall
take care that the laws
"be faithfully executed."
And so, the clearest justification
for an Executive Order
are times when a regulation
is needed or a directive
is needed in order to
faithfully execute the laws.
But as we will see,
Presidents throughout history
have really pushed the boundary
here and have definitely
gone into territory that you might expect
to be the area of Congress.
Now in terms of appreciating how frequent
these Executive Orders are,
here is a chart that gives
the average Executive Orders
per year for the last few Presidents.
And you can see at the low end,
you have President Obama
and President George W. Bush
averaging about 35 or 36
Executive Orders per year.
And then all the way at the high end,
you get to Gerald Ford and Jimmy Carter.
Now if you were to go even
further back in history,
Presidents like Franklin
Roosevelt had far more
Executive Orders than even this.
And just to appreciate some
of the most significant
Executive Orders ever made,
Lincoln's Emancipation
Proclamation in 1863
which was delivered during the Civil War,
it freed nearly three million slaves
in the Confederate states.
In 1942 a few months
after Japan's bombardment
of Pearl Harbor, Franklin Roosevelt issues
Executive Order 9066 which
called for the internment
of Americans of Japanese ancestry.
Historians have really frowned
on this Executive Order
because it was a blatant
disregard for the rights
of these Americans.
But at the time, Franklin
Roosevelt justified it
as a national security issue.
And then in 1952 during the Korean war,
steel workers are
threatening to go on strike.
And so, President Truman
issues Executive Order 10340
that puts steel mills under the control
of the Commerce Secretary.
And the justification
here was that they were
in the middle of the war and that steel
is an essential material
for conducting the war.
Now what's really interesting
about this Executive Order,
is that the owners of the
steel mills did not like this
and they take the
government to Federal court.
It eventually gets to
the U.S. Supreme Court.
It's knows as the case,
Youngstown Sheet and Tube Company
versus Sawyer where Sawyer
was the Commerce Secretary.
And the Supreme Court rules
against President Truman
saying that this Executive
Order went beyond the bounds
of even the President's implied powers.
So the big picture here
is that Executive Orders
are a method by which Presidents
over time have been able
to expand their power beyond
what is explicitly listed
in Article II of the Constitution.
Now like in all things, there
is a check on that power.
And much of that comes from
the Supreme Court's ability
to rule Executive Orders unconstitutional.
But there still aren't clear
boundaries on what makes
an Executive Order constitutional or not.
And they are likely to continue
to be an area of debate
when it comes to powers of the President.